hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to three scary games so
asbestos best slow nice best slow night
hey lik seein you scare them scare them
I'll go I'm gonna go you you give them a
nice spook hey no pressure
you got this hey I trust you I trust you
I trust you
so this game is called the tapes
midnight mom and dad are asleep time to
go watch TV or time for bed so you can
get up and study your hardest tomorrow
examine the poster of my favorite pants
oh no / stupid who's this my poster of
the best person to ever exist you don't
even know their name
alright perfect whoa what just happened
we're I'm sorry I don't know what just
happened there but that was very bizarre
but anyway I guess we're gonna leave now
it's real quiet I didn't want to make
them my parents oh okay it's real quiet
why is it so quiet
they left the TV on yeah I'm sure that's
what happened all channels show static I
better check the back there's a VHS tape
stuck to the back of the DAV find my
tapes oh I bet it's just mom trying to
scare me yeah I need mom I know [ __ ]
another tape in the garage yeah mom let
me show you I'm a big boy I'm a big boy
and I ain't scared of nothing I'm scared
of nothing MA I'll show you I'll scare
you
I'll teach you a lesson
I hated that I hated that of all the
things that I've seen I hate that I'm
not hungry
I should grab that flashlight you know
it's a smart move
I regret this it's even spookier all
right got the tape time to go pop this
in the TV I don't want to go out hey
better shine a flashlight oh good job oh
but there are still more tapes to find
there's a weird cartoon storage room
that's right here yeah you you you right
you ready you really it's my stereo in
front of my room way way way
I know
[Music]
you
you know what you know what what do you
know what do you know what do you know I
don't know no I'm I'm always have never
known nothing watch for the boy don't be
afraid the parents are having a hell of
a time
are they exchanging special presents
with each other
I think I'm slipping the other horse
oh goodness gravy rock on my dude I
think that's what you were doing
I love Smash Mouth ooh where are mom and
dad don't know are you exchanging
special presents with each other almost
there okay very very close it's not even
plugged in what's going on
strange weird hands start grabbing me
from round my head someone's knocking on
the door yeah
use peephole okay can't open it I can
only look through their people okay well
that's good I'm gonna go see what Mama
and Papa up do haha are you having
private shower time I guess this is just
my eyes now oh the weather's really sub
snowing out there I know what the people
looks like fine time to sit down
relaxing movie what I like most about
you oh my goodness that's fun oh wow
is that nothing will stop you TV night
oh it was called TV night not the tapes
wow that was um terrifying yeah I got no
criticism about that was scary though
spooky it really used quiet to its
advantage anyway
good start I'm gonna go clean my pants
then we're gonna move on
this is paralysis or Lulu Z's Lulu Z's
all right
[Music]
I'm assuming this is about the sleep
paralysis variety and not just general
paralysis this game contains loud noises
and is based on true events there may be
true events meaning that everybody gets
sleep paralysis on occasion
not everybody oh my god it is way asleep
oh god what's going on I can't move it
is it seems I can only move my eyes oh
yeah these are my eyes this looks like
my bedroom well yeah I'd be suspicious
if it didn't what are you gonna do to me
I know what you're going to do gonna put
a sleep paralysis demon in there well
then what what the hell is that yeah I'm
asking the same really you're not gonna
put it creepily in the distance for a
little bit you're just gonna brew water
you're just gonna write up in my face
like that whoa well oh well hey listen
hey this is more what I was thinking
about but you can you can stop the
approach there you can
Oh what an intricate design you have in
your ask there
hi hello mmm yeah don't like that whoo
all right then someone mod this game and
put in Ethan on the cups as soon my
sleep paralysis demon move I need to
move the light the light the light I
need to get up
uh-huh okay move left arm huh you
doesn't seem to be helping much whew Oh
am i up oh I'm up but I move very slow
oh no whoa do they turn it off or on
what do they do
what hi my back here dot dot dot I don't
even know how to speak that language
why am i back here I can't move again
the light me wiggle waggle my arm well
that's normal
can I wiggle waggle no hi hello
okay I'm wiggling I'm wiggling is bear
get off of me bear Oh Brigid you got me
there bear but I'm a little wiggle left
and wiggle right oh yeah ah okay oh I
see
ho are you afraid
yeah interesting oh you're interesting
interestingly ugly did you notice
something in the corner of your room
what what did I see it no are you sure
look again now look up oh now look at
the text in the description now look at
the title now look at the hash tag I use
now look in the tags now look in my
comment surprised oh hi yes did you
enjoy that as pretty cool I have another
surprise for you oh good goody goody
gumdrops where's your friend mr. bear I
don't know I don't know a little old
dabeh
oh I can't wait to see you I need to get
the light now I don't even want to get
up hands up there a slowly very slowly
the light click got it nailed it I'm the
best I've done it uh-oh I'm back here
again again Oh can't believe this bull
why I don't know can't move again
hello what the hell all right hey mama
mama hmm that's not right
uncle Jeff okay I'm waiting for the why
it's funny cuz I can't see you I'm
feeling I'm gonna see you
anxiety bangs I oh I'm gonna curb my
anxiety oh it's the baby the baby's
crawling to me well Wow Oh baby got big
baby
hey I don't know if saying that because
oh well hang on let me get my exercise
down there we go got it I don't know if
saying you're my worst nightmare
actually makes you sad thing my asthma
the light oh alright well it better work
this time to tell you
ooh it's finally over I'm back baby I
want to go downstairs for a drink baby
I'm back I'm on a roll I'm back baby
baby I'm back I'm out of control I'm
back baby
wait I don't live in the house is really
over all right okay not bad not bad
not bad but I also have to say it needs
a lot of work in terms of pacing because
right off the bat getting the the viewer
with like an immediate jump scare that
was kind of ridiculous in the first
place
just like set the tone because the whole
concept of like sleep paralysis is that
you can't move and the most horrible
thing to me anyways that whenever I get
sleep paralysis is that I think there's
something and trying to move makes it go
away but it's being locked in that
position and not being able to do
anything that really really makes it I
think there's a lot of stuff to play
with this with just having the viewer be
in bed and not sure of what they're
seeing because that's what sleep
paralysis is all about I've had sleep
paralysis where I'm rolled over to one
side of the bed facing one side of the
room and yet in my dream state I am
looking over there I know that's tough
to explain but it's completely illogical
because the way you dream is is
different and when it slips into reality
that's what makes things seem scary
either way not bad
krytus general here go speaking hey boss
it's me Gail I don't you left holidays I
can't stop thinking about it boss the
letter I can't get it out of my head
something about this one just feels
different different what are you talking
about it's just about the hotel story
again I just think it could be worth
checking out as all I keep thinking I
tell you to not waste time with this
kind of crap these people are lonely
Gail they have nothing better to do they
just want some form of recognition even
this Ben guy he doesn't exist
believe me this is all hogwash I've seen
it for I'm just saying this one feels
different it just doesn't make sense
lying about something like this on the
letter itself something about it really
stuck with me what are you really asking
me here I think I'm asking you to trust
me
listen I'll even bring my own camera do
you have a title I'll figure it out hmm
okay well Benjamin's in the enquires
journal dated january 9th 1979 by Gayle
Smith why only a my left ear yeah your
arrival seems to be expected a single
room key with a note attached someone
here has been waiting for me oh I'm
playing now okay all right then um cool
this is the onlooker and I am Gayle and
we are about to explore the hotel room
for some reason all right thank you
whoever is the patron of this
establishment you are very very lovely
Oh
my camera is Oh all right okay well this
is a fine establishment that is not
something for me to read that is a dog
have you seen our beloved Bob a binky
Bob binky Bob binky you're you are
trying to tell me that that dog's name
is Bob binky maybe that dog ran away
because you gave it such a ridiculous
name when you recall Bob bingi comeback
you didn't know what the hell you were
saying go Bob pinkie sit Bob pinkie lay
down this dog's name is Bob number one
this stock Robert binky binky the dog
that doesn't even look like a Bob
doesn't even look like a binky I never
criticized a dog's name in my life that
dog's name is a binky Bob binky you're
telling me that you had a whole slew of
names and you went with Bob binky I
can't get over this Oh binky doesn't
exist in I just googled it there's no
results I don't know who Bob Bing yeah
this is the scariest thing about this
game so far and I'm just two seconds to
do it Bob binky okay whatever it's fine
it's totally fun I'm gonna overlook that
dog's name all right so I think I'm
going tills glory days might be long
past but the walls are strangely
comforting yeah sure they don't look
like blood no one's like something a
horrible happen here please do not
disturb hey I got a key this is the room
right - OH - oh I thought it was - OH -
yeah maybe it wasn't oh my god is this
game running at two frames a second yeah
it's a little better might have hoped
Benjamin would meet me here but no such
luck Ben binky binky the vent okay
interesting
so what's in the vent also I didn't even
know this place would have a ventilation
system
as a problem
Oh weird
oh cool Oh weird okay I'm into this
that's bizarre okay so what about this
whoa I'm down here now Oh
turns out the door to the mystery was
right here with me all along
Benjamin wanted me to see something Oh
mr. Stevens is back again like an old
friend doesn't your wife worry Isaac
does she know where you are he still
spends all his time eating or wandering
around his room nothing ever changes in
some way it's comforting to watch him
the TV is turned up too loud for him to
hear me knocking on the wall okay weird
disgusting
that looks like a corpse I'm pretty sure
that's blood on the shoes job had a
normal life I went that lion for gray
and for paper to use this is where he
would come to be completely alone turns
out he wasn't much a part of growing up
Wow weird kind of creepy voyeuristic
thing going on here find the key uh
who's leaving me this message why is
this our whole back room thing in here
here's a camera flash to see in dark
places exactly what I was supposed to do
but okay Norma and toad dirty lazy
workers Norman never does anything but
complainant ona is a stupid [ __ ] i watch
them drop some meat on the floor and
still serve it pretty sure they serve
bites of people's foods to the dog as
well that [ __ ] stupid dog Bob angee
he keeps barking at the ceiling he knows
I'm up here I must do something about
him Bob the eating staff going about
their day fulfilling their mundane tasks
little did they know that someone was
keeping an eye on them waiting for Miss
tip she apparently the only moderately
creepy but that's okay oh the lovebirds
they've been here for four weeks don't
they have anywhere to be
never seen far apart skin always
touching in some way almost enough to
make a man jos except Mary is always
just crying Michael is the one with the
black eye this time not really lovebirds
then I guess why am I looking at this
I remember hearing breathing she said
but I wasn't in a state of mind to think
anything of it and she thought her
husband was the only one who knew of her
violent outbursts what are you saying
how do you well how are you saying this
what are you saying this is weird I
don't like this this is creepy in a
different way who's eaten cake who's
eaten fresh cake who got this cake why
is her shoe
why is your boob hanging out what's
going on here oh I'm falling I'm down
here now ah
there were stairs and I just didn't see
them oh alright okay good well this is
odd don't like that don't like that but
it seems like I'm the monster here so
maybe I've got nothing to worry about
just regular old maze of climbing fence
to make a layer dusty and cramped I
wonder if he watched me from his bed
when I arrived yeah maybe yeah maybe
maybe he's down here to kill me Oh
interesting I see I see I see well
wasn't this the guy that left me in the
note to go to the vent in the first
place so it's like he wanted me to see
this right which is bizarre but then
again it's the least bizarre of the
things I've seen of this guy dude he
didn't the shadows of his room to drink
and sleep his days away the stench of
liquor carries through the vent and
becomes an opening for the world to know
his terrible secret
she's Bonin bottle collection is
impressive at this point growing more
and more every day all he does is watch
pornography I'm surprised he can still
get it up with all that alcohol in his
blood the other day I heard him talking
to somebody on the phone it sounded
relatively one-sided to wonder if the
girls in reception are ignoring him on
purpose
they have good reason to yeah you know
I'm just gonna move past that one
like I just wants to spend his days
fapping and drinking I guess that's that
can be done in their own times long as
he doesn't hurt anybody
oh yeah closeted this this this wouldn't
be found ever
very subtle this game's weird found the
key to the secret door take this key I
will show you something why are you
showing me anything should I take that
knife instead of just the key hello is
there nothing else over here Bob binky
got you Bob
Bob being nice it's Bob binky everybody
okay so secret door go back in the room
go to the secret door uh-huh where was a
secret door I don't remember there being
a secret door anywhere Gayle Smith I
know I said I would meet you here and I
will i mrs. before yeah I just need you
to see something first
I'm sure it's only a matter of time
before you realize it will all become
clear to you then enjoy your stay take
your time look around okay I enjoyed my
stay now I have my key and now I need a
secret door where's a secret door this
is bizarre it's just like some strange
like feeling of wrongness like I know
it's a game and all that but just like
watching people this is creepy this is
even before like the day and age when
cameras are everywhere and you know
anyone can hack into anything this door
was this the door I think this might
have been the door
niphas wrong about that where's this
secret door oh I know where it was I'm
an idiot oh god let's see and cut it all
out don't let anyone see my shame of
course I know where it is I know exactly
where it is about no longer it's like no
one ever saw him again he was always
there it was always there here we go I
got it here right on the first try I
knew exactly where that secret door
would be anyway glad you could be here
for me why did you have to peep what's
wrong with you what's wrong with me you
are [ __ ] up I'm [ __ ] up I'm the only
one who sees us for what we are and I
see my part in it waiting for you Gale
there's nothing left for me okay
he ordered grapes wine and she sat on
his couch watching his favorite show
what a life the grape went straight down
his throat and he choked three minutes
he struggled for about three minutes
eventually his face turned blue and his
arms drop dead Isaac Stephens died by
suffocating on a grape I just stood
there watching what
what also he was dead
oh okay
did you see now I let him die let him
die I let him die yeah I see that yeah I
see well what would what could he have
done maybe called the front desk you
know that would have been nice made a
whole world inside these walls and he
made sure nobody knew even though they
were all part of it they had founded
lying I saw the opening and gladly
well I didn't know it was a choice I
didn't know that there was a choice I
saw game and I just did is not my fault
is the end of our story make it a good
one hey bud bud bud bud bud bud listen
listen listen what happened I didn't see
it is that a gun hole Oh
oh my god don't shoot me oh I can't look
away
oh no that's a problem this is a story
about remorse this is a story about
obsession Benjamin couldn't live with
the weight of his sin he had seen too
much and had nobody to tell it to what I
saw what he saw and it still wasn't
enough to shift the blame but the worst
part of it all I think I understand I
didn't realize I didn't have to look I
was thrown so thrown off by Bob binky
Eric halls Tyrone oklets
Tomas Havre my Dell that was a
fascinating story I really enjoyed that
I didn't realize I was enjoying it until
I got to the point where I was like oh
holy [ __ ] that's what it's about
Anders Grondahl Jurgen stole Stein set
Frederick Hoffman hanja rosana's that
was quite good I think
was really good oh yeah oh hey boss I
have the title on okay okay
I like that a lot slow burn but I did
like that that was good
so that was three scary games thank you
everybody so much for watching if you
want to see more scary games you know
where to find him lick see and point
them in the right direction so right
down there in the description thank you
Thank You Lexi and thank you so much for
helping out you're such a yeah you're
just so you're so nice man I don't want
to make you do lots of work you're such
you're so great everyone should
subscribe to you that's what they should
do how long has my door been opened back
there
I I don't go in there it just opens not
a joke
let's you know or it's fine if you can
go you may go
thank you so thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always I'll see you
in the next video
[Music]